resuelve x y en este caso nos están
dando 4 que multiplica el valor absoluto
de x 10 4 y esto es igual a 6 que
multiplica valor absoluto de x + 10
todo esto más 10 vamos a hacer una cosa
y vamos a reescribir esta ecuación de
tal manera que el valor absoluto
simplemente brille y lo podamos ver
fácilmente vamos a poner entonces
tenemos 4 que multiplica el valor
absoluto de x + 10
y esto le sumaremos 4
todo esto será igual a 6
que multiplica el valor absoluto de x 10
y a lo cual les sumaremos también
se ve muy complicado pero vamos a hacer
primero el despeje del valor absoluto de
x + 10 vamos a considerar esto tal vez
como una variable ok tenemos 4 de algo
más 4 que es igual a 6 de algo más 10
usamos esto como una variable
simplemente para que nosotros podamos
eliminar este 6 del lado derecho porque
vamos a pasar absolutamente todos las
variables del lado izquierdo tendremos
entonces que restarle a este 6 valor
absoluto de x + 10
pues le arrestaremos justamente 6 valor
absoluto de x 10
y como es una igualdad aquí vemos el
símbolo de igual haremos exactamente lo
mismo del otro lado estaremos
el valor absoluto de x + 10
con eso hemos pasado las variables del
lado izquierdo y ahora quiero las
constantes del lado derecho este 4 es
una constante siempre será 4 para que yo
pueda quitar este 4 del lado izquierdo
lo que haré es tengo un 4 sumando
entonces resta de 4
y como lo que le hice al lado izquierdo
se lo he de hacer al lado derecho para
mantener la igualdad restar e de este
lado también 4
y con esto vamos a tener ahora
lo siguiente
si yo tengo cuatro de algo y le restó
seis de ese mismo algo realmente lo que
estoy haciendo es quitarle a 46 vamos a
ponerlo más sencillo si yo tengo 4
manzanas y le quito 6 manzanas ahora
tendré menos dos manzanas bueno creo que
de hecho es ejemplo de las manzanas
tampoco nos ayuda vámonos con los
números si ya tengo cuatro de esta
variable y le quito 6 de esta variable
ahora tendré 2
negativo de esta variable vamos a
pasarlo como tal
- 2 valor absoluto de x + 10 este 4
positivo se cancela con este 4 negativo
por lo que directamente nos iremos a la
igualdad y apropósito lo que hicimos fue
poner este 6 de la variable y le
restamos el 6 de la variable recuerdan
es por eso que salió este por lo tanto
se cancela tengo un 6 positivo y un 6
negativo de esa variable se cancelan y
tendremos únicamente entonces esta resta
tengo más 10 menos 4 es igual a más 6
vamos a escribirlo aquí es igual a 6
positivo
vamos avanzando ahora lo que haremos es
despejar esta variable valor absoluto de
x + 10 para ello tenemos un 2 negativo
multiplicando si esto está multiplicando
la manera en la que podemos cancelar lo
será dividiendo entre menos 2
pero lo que le haga lado izquierdo
recuerda esto es una igualdad se lo debe
hacer al lado derecho así es que viviré
entre -2 con eso tendremos entonces la
cancelación de estos dos y nos quedará
valor absoluto de x más 10 que será
igual a
6 entre menos 2 igual a menos 3
y esto nos pone en una situación muy muy
interesante recuerda que el valor
absoluto es que tanta distancia tengo de
ese número hacia el cero pero el valor
absoluto tiene la propiedad de no
negatividad siempre será positivo vamos
a escribir eso eso es importante el
valor absoluto siempre será positivo por
lo que tendría que ser mayor o igual a
cero y en este caso tenemos un menos 3
no hay posibilidad alguna que este
número
qué es un valor absoluto sea negativo
dada la característica o la propiedad
que tiene el valor absoluto de no
negatividad por lo tanto esto
simplemente nos dice que no tiene
respuesta no tiene solución posible
vamos a escribirlo no tiene
solución
posible
y pondremos signos de admiración porque
es importantísimo
que no lo olvidemos ok por lo tanto esa
es nuestra respuesta esta ecuación no
tiene solución posible